let's get some more practice finding the
angle in this in these cases the
positive angle between the positive
x-axis and a vector drawn in standard
form where its initial point or its tail
is sitting at the origin and so here for
vector AI we can we can write it in two
different ways in engineering notation
it would be negative two times a unit
vector I - that's the unit vector in the
X Direction minus four times the unit
vector in the Y direction or we can just
say its X component is negative two its
Y component is negative four and we see
that here if we're starting at the
origin we go to to the left and we go
four down to get to the terminal point
or the head of the vector let's figure
out what theta is
well we've seen before the weaken when
we're thinking about vectors drawn in
standard form we could say the tangent
of this angle is going to be equal to
the Y component over the X component so
the Y component is negative 4 and the X
component is negative 2 and in the
previous video we explained why this is
it really comes straight out of the unit
circle definition of trig functions
tangent of theta is equal to the y
coordinate over the x coordinate of
where though we're a line that defines
an angle intersects the unit circle and
we talked I encourage you to watch that
video if that doesn't make much sense
but so we so we could say tangent of
theta is equal to 2 and so we might want
to say if we want to solve for theta we
could say theta is equal to the inverse
the inverse tangent function of 2 and
I'm going to put a question mark and you
I think you you might know why I'm
putting that question mark so let's see
what that gets us so if we were to take
2 and I want to take the inverse tangent
not just the tangent I want to figure
out what what angle gives me a tangent
of 2 so inverse tangent inverse tangent
it's about sixty three point four
degrees roughly so this gives me theta
is approximately sixty three sixty three
point four degrees and I'm going to put
a question mark here and I think you
might sense why that is if you don't
pause the video and think about why why
am i putting a question mark here why
does this why does this angle look fishy
well it looks fishy because an angle of
63.4 degrees would put us squarely in it
would put a squarely in the first
quadrant if our if our vector looked
like if our vector looked like this let
me see if I can draw it if our vector
whoops we get the if our vector looked
like this
so if our vector if our vectors
components were positive 2 and positive
4 then that looks like a 63 degree angle
this looks like a 63 degree angle but
we're not in the first quadrant our
vector a that we care about is in the
third quadrant so it's clear that it is
another it's in the exact opposite
direction and I think you see why when
we take the inverse tangent function on
our calculator it assumes that the angle
is between negative 90 degrees and
positive 90 degrees while here we have
an angle that's over 180 degrees it's
between 180 and 270 degrees and so to
find this angle this is why if you're
ever using the inverse tangent function
on your calculator it's very very
important whether you're doing vectors
or anything else so think about where
where does your where does your angle
actually sit what what quadrant does it
actually put you in because you might
have to adjust those figures so it's not
going to be sixty three point four
degrees it's going to be that plus
another 180 degrees to go all the way
over here so theta is going to be 180
and I should say approximately because I
still rounded 180 plus 63 point four
degrees is going to be 200 and what is
that 180 plus 60 is 240 so 240 three
point four degrees so let's do one more
so here I have a vector sitting in the
fourth quadrant like we just did pause
the video and see if you can figure out
the positive angle that it forms with
the positive x-axis well we could do the
same we could do the same drill and
maybe we could skip a few steps here now
that we've done it many times we might
want to say that the inverse tangent of
let me write it this way we might want
to write it in the same color we might
want to say that theta is equal to the
inverse tangent
of my y-component over my x-component of
negative six over four and we know what
that is but I'll just let me just
actually not skip too many steps so the
inverse tangent of negative 1 point 5
negative 1 negative 1 point 5 and once
again I get to get my calculator out and
so 1 point 5 negative and I want to find
the inverse tangent of it I get roughly
negative 56 point three degrees so this
is approximately equal to negative fifty
three point six degrees I do that right
yet fifty six point three fifty six
point three degrees and once again I'm
going to put the question marks here and
why did I do that because the angle that
it's giving and this isn't wrong
actually in this case it's just not
giving us the positive angle because if
you start at the positive x-axis and you
were to go clockwise well now your your
angle is going to be negative and that
is negative 56 point three degrees but
we want to figure out the positive angle
right over here so there's a couple of
ways that you could think about doing it
one way to think about it as well to go
from this negative angle to the positive
version of it we have to go completely
around once so we have to add 360
degrees so if it's really approximately
negative 56.3 degrees plus 360 degrees
which is going to be what is that so
it's going to be let me write a deck
this so it's going to be approximately
so see if I subtract it 50 degrees I
would get to 310 degrees I subtract
another six degrees so it's 304 degrees
and then point three so three hundred
and three point seven degrees it I do
that right let's see if I add if I add
this point three to the seven that's
going to get to 304 then a 310 to 360 so
there you go that is our positive angle
that we form so always really think
about what what they're asking from you
or what a question is asking from your
one well anyway you get the idea
you